dude what was that
talk why are you being so rude why are
you causing a problem in front of
everybody are we still rolling actually
this is kind of pissing me off like why
are you making this a problem what the
[ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone do we just become best friends
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to a
very spontaneous episode of the unwaxed
podcast with your favorite sisters
sophia and sistine and scarlett um
always says it like that you always do
that and scarlett
um
we actually he's a third sister yes well
we had a cancellation so we thought
let's call the backup in yeah and she
showed up yeah
i woke up at
um 10 sistine calls me at 10 10.
um rush over here as quick as possible
and now now i'm here we're great well we
very much appreciate it scarlett i do um
you kind of came in a little bit
frazzled though i came very frazzled
there's two things on my mind my hair is
falling out because i dyed it all blonde
and the second one is that my wallet got
stolen in new york
okay okay yeah i want to go let's break
it down let's break down the first one
yeah
my wallet got stolen oh that wasn't the
first one oh my hair's falling out
but no i don't know if i dyed it
i don't know if it's me dying in leech
blonde or i'm stressed i don't know no
i'll tell you what it is um scarlet and
i have a bad habit of cheating on our
hairdresser
and
i
always think that i'm going to get a
different result but it's always worse
than what my hairdresser can do
so uh i go in saying i want like a
natural light brown i come back with
black hair and scarlett goes in saying
she wants blonde and now she has no hair
but it's different scarlet because i
have no hair you guys are talking about
cheating on your hairdresser but
breakage like what we have is just
because i'm not taking off my hat no
we're bonding
we're dyeing our hair too blonde you're
fine because you're going brunette well
when you're blonde it's absolutely
hypothetically if you were to take off
your hat right now are we talking like
dr phil are we talking just like a
little male pattern baldness let's just
think okay so you're comparing your hair
to what my hair looks like ooh tea
sophia because we both are blonde and
who has worse hair right now you are
sophia
me yeah probably scarlet actually 100 i
thought i thought
i think for the past three times i've
gotten my hair done i literally have
gone to three different people and it's
not good because every time you get
something you kind of didn't ask for
because i don't know your hair at all
so let's break down part two your wallet
got stolen how the hell do you plan on
getting home without an id
yeah i know um you have no credit card
no credit card no cash no id no
in new york city
so i should say go out
i don't know how she's supposed to get
food
more importantly scarlet rogue in the
city how did she what's your plan room
service
that's it
one dollar slice of pizza
i got some change i'll take it out of my
bag
it's been really stressful i woke up
frazzled because i couldn't find my
wallet what happened i i don't know so i
went to the restaurant last night and i
put
my
bag on the chair and then
i looked into my bag and my wallet is
gone
do you think you maybe left it in a cab
i feel like you probably left on the
couch scar
what couch like where a chair that
you're sitting on how do you know you
didn't just drop it near the table i
called the restaurant they're looking
for it this is i've never bought this is
i don't think someone sees you in a
nutshell
yeah if any experience could describe
your life you know the amount of times
you've left wallets
i just don't
understand that i blame everything on me
being a gemini
that is okay i'm sorry that is not get
out of jail free card that's almost as
bad as like when you judge someone based
on their zodiac sign
i have a problem so i have a question
when you tell mom and you know she's
gonna freak out are you gonna say mom
look i can't help it i'm a gemini is
that your excuse i always tell mom that
yeah she screams at me she's gonna
scream at you i know i don't know what
to do i get nervous so i was like sorry
i lost a hundred dollars i'm a gemini
mom scares me you can't do that you're
on my flight how do you plan on getting
on a plane yeah you can't get on a plane
if you don't have your id
oh [ __ ] they're actually oh
this is actually a problem we're not
just saying you know what i think you
did this on purpose you might have to go
down you've been wanting to like live in
new york move to new york i think you
did this you could stay here longer
well can i do you think i can well i
don't think you have a choice how do you
pay for it
you might have to go downstairs there's
a card on phone that's it there's a card
on file yeah but yeah but i'm not i'm
not going with dad home no i'm not
leaving i love new york i'm going to
move here
no because i got anybody levine cookies
every day
you know i don't really like them i told
you i took one bite and i was like uh
it's so mad i told you was it too sugary
or is it too plain is it lavender
lavonne i don't know is it lavon living
oh yeah i don't know i don't i don't
know but either way i didn't really like
it how has it been since uh you're here
with your not boyfriend boyfriend oh not
boyfriend boyfriend's great um we had so
much fun and then we were both stressing
about the wallet thing last night but he
really wanted to come on today like he
really wanted to i think the next time
he will when we planned this out
recording well we would love to talk to
your not boyfriend boyfriend that
slightly resembles dad i would love to
pick his brain about it literally said
to him michael you are a cop i i
literally told him to his face you are a
copying page well that's what a lot of
yeah he is girls do by the way they date
their dad yeah it's normal creepily
enough when i was young
what you drinking oh yeah what are you
drinking vitamin c oh looks like this i
was gonna say the same thing anyways
anyway
when i was young i don't know if you
guys remember this but i used to always
tell mom that i was like you're gonna
divorce dad because i'm gonna marry him
i was so young that i didn't actually
understand the dynamic but that's not
normal
yeah this was really weird you weren't
married what a married dad but i was so
little and i was i thought it was a
normal thing to do that was so weird it
was so weird i don't know why i just
didn't have a normal um
school crush well you guys went out to
dinner last night without me how was
that
did we it it was oh
lemon cello shots that wasn't lemon
cello there's like what is lemoncello
they're called lemon juice like an
italian
drink yeah so we basically took shots
and had a lot of glasses of wine and a
cannoli the size of sistine's forearm it
was delicious
it was from anyway scarlett you've been
kind of solo in new york which is i've
been completely alone so your vibe
though i love it i think you would for
first scholar you've always been the
type that wants to be alone rather than
around people yeah and this city is
probably the perfect place to do it what
are you perfect it's lonely it's dark
it's but i would like love just to stalk
you like what does a day in your life in
new york look like walk me through it
okay so you're interviewing her like
she's a cat she is so funny the way you
are i should be treated like a story
tell us about your day in the life of
new york okay i'm sorry it is kind of
funny
anyways as the guest is talking
yeah
um
i i honestly i don't think you
understand like i don't even know what
i'm going to do that day i don't wake up
and go okay i'm gonna have this this
this this done i wake up i put on some
pants put on the same hoodie that i've
been wearing for the past four days in a
row and walk
i walk i walk i walk i walk for
literally three hours straight so you
let your feet
guide you i don't know i i
i just find a bunch of like weird things
to do i end up like running into people
and talking to strangers and
buying hats for my dead hair and you
know it's just like doing like really
random things but those all don't sound
very interesting to you i talk to
strangers i buy hats for my hair that's
falling out i feel like you but
i wish you guys when i lose my walls
i don't know i i i like to explore i
don't i haven't been here in five years
and i just kind of you know get lost i
feel like you base it based on what you
want to try that day food wise you're
like okay i'm going to walk to this
croissant yeah are you you're like the
foodie she literally was telling me i'm
going to find the best egg bagel
sandwich i'm going to find the best
croissant
i didn't find anything but there's like
a deli that doesn't mean that's not what
she does like you have been doing that
you're like i'm gonna find the best one
and that means you're gonna go explore i
mean i haven't had any
okay well that's what you were telling
me so i'm assuming you're walking around
the city maybe you'll stop and you find
like a bagel shop and you're like oh
maybe i'm going to try this and this is
going to be fun i did i did like walk
around for a couple hours and then i
realized it was like 3 p.m and i was
like i need breakfast so i so i walked
into a um i walked into a croissant
store hadn't it was kind of weird it was
like a little sketchy and i bought like
four croissants and i ate by myself
[Music]
sophie and i really love to work power
through things and we often put
our stress on the back burner yeah and i
think also another thing that adds on to
that is when we're traveling especially
right now i mean we're in new york city
and just this whole trip has been kind
of
building up a little bit of anxiety i
don't know
with the work schedule with yeah
managing our family lives our friendship
lives our relationship lives it can be a
lot and it's very stressful and sophia
and i have actually been
using this product that has seriously
changed so much our life and we realize
that you don't have to feel stressed all
the time and using prima has actually
changed our entire life but i only even
think people realize that 75 to 90
doctor visits are for stress related
issues see that's insane it's insane
because many of us are operating all the
time on survival mode we expect our skin
our bodies our minds to thrive when
we're seriously running on empty yeah so
what's great about prima it's california
we're from california it's a lead
purpose-based cbd hemp product that just
is the best way to relieve stress and
why i love them so much is they are
dedicated to helping you rise above
modern day stress so every day is a
little bit better with their doctor
formulated clinically validated high
performance products for the skin body
and mind so if you're not sure where to
start because i know that when it comes
to these products you're just a little
bit overwhelmed they have daily cbd
capsules that you can just take on the
go to relieve that stress i love these
gummies because you know it's fun just
to take a little bit of sweetness
throughout by the way
delicious it's so good kiss or you can
go at night and you use sleep tight
because i know that she also has this
problem we don't sleep i know we talked
about her od on melatonin this has been
the best
alternative i don't have to overdose on
melatonin congratulations
has literally given me some of the best
sleep of my life so lucky for us prima
is offering our listeners an exclusive
limited time
20
offer with the code unwax trust us
because i feel like you guys are
convinced at this point so head to prima
dot co and get that 20 off using the
code unwax and get the relief you
deserve by using the products today
[Music]
you know your schedule honestly is kind
of alarming
like for you what time do you sleep in
until noon if you wanted you eat
breakfast at three
you know
you put on the same pants every day you
said it's uh are you okay
no
okay
i was i don't know i'm i think i'm just
very lost right now unlike what i want
to do for a career do you mean just lost
in the city um
not for career at all i mean i'm 90
years old i'm a college student i just
don't know what i'm doing in the future
like i have no idea if i want to live in
l.a next year i don't know if i want to
live in miami next year i don't know if
i you know maybe live in new york next
year but who knows but i just like i'm
very confused on where i want to go to
college what i want to do like i don't
is your boyfriend have an opinion on the
matter
no he just said whatever he goes i just
want you to be happy at the end of the
day because no matter what you do just
he goes don't base your decision off of
me that is the last thing i want you to
do because you're not happy then you are
not happy and you know
um he goes because the last thing he
goes i would be really sad if like you
stayed at the school and you weren't
happy but you only stayed for me because
that was like kind of my mind process i
was like i would stay for him that's
really important
but yeah yeah he was really
understanding but we talked about that
last night and
i just don't know what i'm doing by the
way scarlett i don't know what i'm doing
tonight like i don't know what i'm gonna
be in a year and
you know if you're gonna be a guest on
the show you'd better know to turn your
phone off i did i did do you see that
actually that's pretty wild yo do you
see what joe's been through
well then whoever's calling must be
important
put joe on facetime right now get him on
the phone i want to talk to this chap
okay he was supposed to be on the show
i want to see what he's doing this much
better than this podcast
hey give me the phone
hello joe you are on the on wax podcast
we are live right now
and we are wondering
joe we are wondering
why
yeah that sounds a little hard to
believe
i really wanted to make the podcast it
was short notice it was short that's
fair that was fair
short notice but sometimes causes for
the best content my friend so
next time i guess
all right joe i'll call you later
bye
so that's really nice of him that he
gives you a
sort of yeah freedom to choose what you
want i know i wish it was like i
literally wish she was here right now
because he'd be like you talk about it
like but you spent last
the last few days with him yeah i know i
spent like one day with him how did you
wait how did you meet joe i actually
leave enough i asked you that before in
an elevator
um we were in our dorms and so i walked
into an elevator he walked into it and
um
i said
why are you dressed like that because he
was dressed in like a full-on
weird racquetball suit yeah why are you
dressed
like so that was like my first words and
i go wait
what are you wearing yeah and he goes
playing racquetball and i go
nice i think i was gonna get her number
can i get your number yeah and that's it
that's like what happened by the way
it's that easy it's definitely one of
the most complicated what's this no
boyfriend boyfriend situation because
there's no label but he's acting like
your boyfriend well they just want to
wait and see where she's gonna end up
next year i don't yeah that's what i
mean like why would i get into a full-on
committed relationship right now if i'm
literally gonna
dip
potentially
i don't know i don't know if i should
what do you think should i stay in l.a
move to miami that's not for us sorry
i think
you need to spend a month there for
summer in l.a and then figure it out
because first year of college is always
stressful for everyone it's so much
transition so much change you almost
spend the whole year just trying to get
settled and then to leave and start that
over against a lot of work yeah and yeah
it sucks because like i need to make a
decision soon one day find out pay for
my next week
when do you find out if you got into the
la school um
i find out i thought it was now
it's may 19th
oh i find out in lately two days oh
well sorry then that's by the way that's
a whole part of it i really hope i don't
get in
so i can make the decision like a lot
what if i applied to school and then we
went together and then i could follow
you around all day you and me going to
college together and what are we
studying we are studying um
sexology
and
i'm not interested psychology has some
facts about kissing she was writing down
she wants no you ruined i had a good
transition for that oh okay we're gonna
rewind my transition was scarlet so
you spent the last day with joe
what is this
so here we go because you guys are
dating not dating you and joe you know
kiss
ew
but yes am i wrong yeah but like why am
i talking about this because i have
facts about kissing that i thought might
interest you if you'd like to hear them
yes and you too sofia with the boyfriend
i know you're kissing you're kissing
hard oh we're kissing a lot possibly
with tongue
of course with time guys
are you french kissing ew
french kissing yeah i don't kiss with
tongue i don't like something you don't
kiss with tongue no it's gross what do
you just close mouth the whole time to
each their own to each other
i kiss like um
like a fish gasping for air
okay
okay here are my facts about kissing
did you know
that kissing for one minute burns 23
calories
seriously
did you know that you are exchanging 10
million to 1 billion bacteria when you
make out with someone that's disgusting
i know
good chemistry when kissing could mean
that you have healthy offspring
means like your babies are healthy if
your chemistry is good
our kissing is if the chemistry is good
with the other person then offspring
will be good the baby will be that's
just who knows
when deciding to kiss someone women pay
more attention to the person's breath
and teeth than men do which
i could probably agree with that um
yeah no no
you don't pay attention to their breath
so if they have stank breath you're like
come here oh wait yeah yeah obviously
yeah
on average one person can spend twenty
thousand one hundred and sixty minutes
kissing oh that's not how much time do
you spend on the toilet what was that
fact
it was like
something amount of years of your life
like ten fifteen i thought it was four
years of your life you spent on the
toilet that makes sense probably more
for me do you know we sleep
why wait
no you're not let's get into it oh you
wanna try my my bathroom breaks yeah why
do you spend so much time on the toilet
i was making a joke but um i don't know
girls don't poop that's why i was
kidding that's true whoever said we do
is stupid they're crazy i don't know why
they would make those assumptions about
us i know
what you want to do with him this
weekend because the weekend's coming up
then without a wallet what are you guys
gonna do oh yeah how are you gonna get
around with no cash
i know you guys i'm freaking out i have
no idea what i'm gonna do well you know
i'm actually genuinely talking to you
and i'm not like even like no you're at
the podcast right now like i'm checking
i have a plan like i'm
genuinely know i started like balling my
eyes out this morning and then i have
then like literally not even 10 minutes
later you call me sorry and and you're
like that's why i was so frazzled on the
phone you're like oh you um come to the
studio right now and i was literally so
frazzled on the phone i that's why i was
like i don't know if i can come like i
don't know if i can do this like blah
blah blah blah yeah you were not saying
anything i was like hello no because i
was freaking out
i was in the lobby literally going to
every like place i went to in the hotel
asking for people while you were calling
me too i was just freaking out you're
stuck in new york
i'm okay with that i'm gonna live here
mark my words i'm living in the city i
have two options for you one
i'd give you some cash
but you're gonna have to work for it
what yeah
nothing's free what do you want me to do
what do you want me to do for you
i got a few errands i need to run
got a few people i need to pay off you
could just be my messenger my gopher and
i think we'll be straight two
you could throw yourself in front of a
cab oh get hit not hurt just hit hey
maybe get some money from that no
um i almost got hit by a cop the other
day oh you've been getting yeah let's
talk about that i wasn't going to bring
it up unless you were this is steve was
so mad at me so um i haven't been to new
york in five years
i'm the one with this
so me and cecine are walking around and
um cece wanted to bring me to this like
little cute market so we're walking
we're walking and i'm i'm like wow i
love this city i'm like looking around
doing my thing getting excited and i'm
walking across the street and
you forgot a bunch of steps i didn't
forget a bunch of steps i walked on the
street i wasn't looking in both
directions the cab almost came and it
was like 10 feet away from me not 10
feet
let me explain what happened
we are walking to this market correct i
have no idea what's going on
the crosswalk is not green we cannot go
there's about 10 people behind us on one
side of the street 10 people on the
other no one's crossing and i get in new
york everyone's jaywalking and when you
live there you sort of know when is an
appropriate time to cross if there are
no cars coming scarlet's not from there
so all of these people that you could
tell are from new york no it's not a
good time to cross but scarlett goes nah
today this is the good time to cross i'm
gonna go for it she runs out into
oncoming traffic a cab is going a little
too fast for my liking and it wasn't ten
feet it was easily five feet from you
maybe closer
they lay on the horn there were people
on both sides gasping at what they just
saw her and i was pissed and scarlett
you just said to me right after she goes
sistine i'm sorry can we just move on
and have fun today i don't wanna i was
like i almost just witnessed my sister
die on the first day that we're here
please don't
god forbid if you were hit
how was i going to explain that to mom
and dad on my watch oh what i'm not four
what am i gonna say she's a gemini she
just went for it okay
i'm not a i'm not a dog sister and like
if i'm i'm 19 like if i get hit by a car
that's all meat but you know what that's
a good idea actually i should put you on
one of those leashes so you can't run
into there's no way you can live here on
your own if you're already getting hit
by traffic hey i'm just getting adjusted
to the city but
scarlet's been here for four days uh
almost dies almost dies loses her wallet
and the city is not free
the city is not i'm gonna come after you
the city is my
and she still hasn't found a good bacon
egg and cheese bagel so the city is not
for you and i don't like lebron
oh well but at least it's better than
oklahoma when you were there oh yeah
let's talk about that how's your
experience been on set and working with
dad oh my god it's been
unreal this is kind of like a dream come
true for me i mean i've wanted to act my
whole entire life and you know i i saw
i've always like pictured dad and i
being on screen together but
never in my life i think it would ever
happen
but i kind of like manifested it a
little bit ever since i was like 14 i
wrote in like the back of my book like
i'm going to start a movie with dad even
though it's not starring in a movie but
it's it's like one liners together but
it's it's a dream come true i'm i'm
acting with my dad and like that's
that's something i've
literally have dreamt about since i was
like a little girl so
um yeah but it's also
really funny to work with him because he
likes to kind of mess with me a little
bit on set yeah like while filming yeah
like we um
like during the scene he would say you
know random he would throw in a little
like
curveballs here and there he's
ad-libbing yeah but like he can't do
that because
no one's going to correct him they're
going to correct the me they're not
going to correct him the scripts are
advised to be like scarlett you're right
so dog comes up to me and he and he's
saying his lines and then he says
something so random so i respond with
like
to kind of coordinate with the line that
he just said that's not on the script
but if i kept going with my lines then
it would make no sense like it don't
seem what it makes sense yeah so the guy
kept coming up to me like scarlett
you're saying this wrong scott you're
saying this wrong i go i'm not the man
just doesn't know his line can we can we
um
recreate
one line of your dialogue with this
coffee mug because scarlett plays a
barista now give us your line in
character
picture her with a note what's your name
with cracked nails and do you have a
tattoo i do have three tattoos
what's your name spencer spencer
spencer deliver your line she is a
barista and
scene
dwight double cappuccino come on say
without laughing oh it's horrible you're
not getting the part again do it come on
that's it it's just dwight double
cappuccino but say it like that you're
spencer oh double shot espresso oh oh so
the line was wrong
i mean it's double cappuccino i remember
you
spencer you're fired from being a
barista i'll tell you that double okay
to be fair i said these lines a while
ago don't you have lines coming up soon
yeah i have to go back what's your line
that you have to say it's uh
um have you studied your lines i yeah i
know my lines what's your new line am i
allowed to say it yeah yeah
okay
say it okay come on spencer
okay should i do my western accent no
it's so bad that's old pilot
don't cappuccino
why don't you just have double cabbage
that's not a thing unless i have never
heard of that it's a double espresso by
the way it's espresso you guys keep
saying with an expression no espresso
you keep saying express it there's no x
in it it's espresso stress out don't eat
the cup
scarlett and i were running lines for
like 20 minutes before she did her first
scene
and she kept saying express and every
time i was like espresso espresso and
she crashed off it's like your brain
doesn't actually absorb what i say i
can't i have a speech delay no
okay i have a question what would be
your dream acting job like would it be
i always wanted to do like lara croft
that was the next life tomb raider or
something really cool in action like
what would yours be like um like being
like
marvel or something anything yeah if i
was a superhero or something like that
oh hunger
spider woman yeah spider is there a
spider well is that cause you just want
to work with tom holland
no oh i would say yes i want a better
spider i mean i like no one is
spider woman's not okay i think right no
no
my dream role is garlic i don't cheat i
don't think
two espressos
[Applause]
i don't think spider woman is a thing
and i don't think the devil shot at
cappuccino
spiders she's like
she goes she goes barista day
spider woman night thanks brazil
all right so who would be your tom
holland that you'd want to work beside
your dream co-star yeah
you could probably kiss him in the movie
you know it's your movie you can do what
you want
um
oh
wait no scott's like ice skater during
the day
shut up
i don't know
could be murphy you can't take mine i'm
sorry what have you ever liked i'm sorry
i'm sorry does he know you does he know
you
but scrub but he was my screensaver
he's mine
yeah 15. like no i was uh
i was 20. you can't claim celebrity men
that you have no yeah but you're like
louis cartridge or like scott who's
another guy
who's another person
um i'm i'm curious because i want to see
if it's weird i know they're all
watchers say jason momoa tom holland no
no tom hardy
don't say tom hardy that's mine
it's like my god the chokehold we have
on these men thinking that they know
this
venom venom venom best movie ever i mean
it's like going to my um tick tock likes
i'm sorry i have a bunch of
your tic tac likes watch them be like
baseball boys that have maybe no no not
my likes like i like them like i like
they're all just golfers oh they're all
golfers but they're like those kids
garlic is like a frat boy
shock or whatever yeah
interesting i have a bunch of likes from
him recently
i don't know about that you're playing
catwoman with robert matt no you're not
just like random guys on dick doc i can
see him certainly do you have a tick
tock crush
who's the cutest boy on tick tock
that golfer
so just a stranger that no one knows
yeah no i thought you guys liked like
josh richards or something oh
oh my god he is so cute
i can't i'm not saying anything okay
he's too young yeah he's 20 well he's
20.
listen when i was at stagecoach was i on
a mission yeah but i never saw him josh
if you're interested
it was uh
it was a low moment i was having a low
low moment i was going through it i was
going through it and i was supporting it
unfortunately i should have
stopped it before it was getting too
dangerous but we never we never saw him
so
nothing happened i'm really concerned
for you to be quite honest why yeah if
you can't get out of new york mom's
gonna kill you you're missing you gotta
stop it's okay
like i really don't know what you're
gonna do i don't i don't know but you
can work for me i will allow that you
guys i don't know what to do
uh
well
maybe why aren't you talking i i'm
trying to think of something to say like
seriously
dude what was that
talk why are you being so rude
sophia seriously you're actually like
being so annoying are you joking you
made me knock over a mug
are you seriously gonna blame me now for
you knocking over a mug
okay sophia that's really stupid i get
you had like
no sleep last night but so did everyone
else and
why are you causing a problem in front
of everybody are we still rolling
this is kind of pissing me off like why
are you making this a problem because
i'm getting my blood boiling right now
i'm sorry that you guys are all here for
this this is like kind of embarrassing
um you know sophia if you have problems
in your own life if you're in a
relationship i actually like you've been
projecting on me since the moment i
walked in this
stop laughing come on
i'm kidding
i got so nervous sofia that's why you're
not the actor of the family
by the way you didn't catch on until
like 30 seconds no no i did i did no
right when you were like why are you not
talking at that at first i was like i'm
trying to think it's like yeah you got
mad and
[Laughter]
did you get it no oh you just got punked
again wait hold on
you just got punched and i've ruined it
and sophia broke character so it really
didn't work did you get her face
i was just like what the hell is
happening
i knew this was okay good
no i the first time i was like sophia
like why aren't you saying anything you
were like dude what's your problem
because i forgot that
still happening oh my god all right well
our next our next guest is coming soon
we want to thank you for being a last
call invite to this thing i really will
help you
with
all of your um wait
what
okay
um okay we'll see you just they didn't
find it yet
oh okay
if anyone wants to give scarlet money
but you know what scarlett this is what
we're going to do we're going to put
skull in times square and dress her up
as spider woman and you just pay her
we're going to put your character as
spider woman who can't pronounce
espresso
please any cash that you have
spreadsheet so let this girl survive new
york city for at least a couple more
hours
we'll be nice just wait she's our little
sister someone needs to help her
where's the sticker in the middle of
times square next to the cowboy we'll
see you next tuesday
cut the cameras
[Music]